por johnson ha advertido a vladimir
putin de que cometerá un error trágico
de cálculos e invade ucrania lo ha hecho
en una llamada telefónica que tenía
pendiente desde el lunes y que viene
precedida de serias advertencias
putin se había quejado de que no se ha
satisfecho la principal demanda de rusia
de garantías de seguridad
el presidente ruso también le ha dicho a
johnson que quiere está involucrada en
el sabotaje crónico de los acuerdos de
minsk diseñados para alcanzar un punto
de la resolución político en ucrania
logrando mayor autonomía bombas el
camino ha dicho cómo va a responder una
vez más pero ha dicho que sigue
esperando una respuesta favorable de la
otan a unas preocupaciones que rusia
considera de sobra justificadas el
ministro de asuntos exteriores de rusia
serguéi lávrov también se ha dirigido en
las últimas horas a eeuu para pedir que
contesten de manera afirmativa a las
preocupaciones rusias rusas sobre su
propia seguridad